[Music]
we love the descendants but there are
plenty of things out there you never
knew about these movies stay tuned to
the end when we tell you about the news
that shocked the cast if this is your
first time visiting us then make sure
you give this video a like and subscribe
to the things today we are looking at 10
dark secrets and descendants Tiffany
doesn't want you to know the Thai food
one of the most memorable scenes in
descendants to comes about halfway
through the film Carlos and Evie have to
convince Ben how to fit in to the Isle
of the Lost
they do this by singing the awesome song
chillin like a villain however what you
might not have known was that this scene
ended up being very hard to film it was
shot in a factory in Vancouver British
Columbia Canada however as the cameras
were rolling in the cast were getting
ready to put in a great performance the
weather struck in the form of a typhoon
descendants to director Kenny Ortega
says that he is proud of everyone who
worked on that part of the film because
you wouldn't have known just how bad
conditions were he says that the sets
were blowing away and the rain was
coming down in buckets right as the
stars were singing and dancing this was
the very last part of descendants 2 to
be filmed on-location and it is one of
our favorite scenes in the movie Kenny
Ortega says it was a real challenge
because he had to make sure that
everyone was safe and no one panic he
obviously did his job brilliantly
because watching it you wouldn't know it
was being shot during a typhoon doves
bruises it's not uncommon for people to
have accidents of one kind or another
while at work it's easy enough to trip
or to hurt yourself or to even saw our
paper cut the mats is truths if you're a
movie star on set as if you are working
in an office it certainly looks true
enough if you are dove Cameron dove who
stars as mal in The Descendants
franchise has spoken about some things
that happened to her while she was
making descendants to dub went under her
Twitter and told her fans that things
were not as easy as people might think
that they were in fact she said that it
seemed like every day she was leaving
this set with a lot of different bruises
however she also laughed it off saying
that all it was was a way of showing
that she was committed to her craft of
acting but the one thing we don't know
because dub didn't tell us was exactly
what those bruises were and how she
managed to get them thanks to either the
technological magic of CGI or the
old-fashioned magic
the movies makeup department we didn't
see them on screen either Harry and Gil
in the run-up to descendants 2 coming
out there was one photo that got a lot
of attention it looked like Thomas
Doherty aka Harry hook and Dylan
Playfair aka
Gill we're kissing this certainly got
people interested and sparked some
interesting theories we wondered whether
it might mean that we would for the
first time see an official gay couple in
a Disney movie bear in mind that when
the photo came out we hadn't yet met
either Harry or Gill so there was a lot
of speculation about who they were the
other idea people had was that Thomas
had broken up with Duff Cameron it was
no dating Dylan when people who saw the
photo saw the movies they wondered
whether the studio had thought a kiss
between two male characters would be a
bit too controversial
so they edited it out at the last minute
but the kiss was never actually in the
movies script but here's the crazy thing
in the novelization of the movie Gill
and Harry kissed so here's a new theory
perhaps something might develop between
Gaston Sun and James hooks son in
descendant 3 or maybe they were together
in descendants - we just didn't see it
descendants dancing if you had to talk
about something that the descendants
movies have a lot oh then you'd picked
an Seng close to the top of the list
after all it is kind of a musical
musicals have dances that go with the
songs but just because it has dancing
that doesn't automatically mean that
everyone who is in the film is the
greatest dancer in fact some of the cast
were chosen because they weren't as good
at dancing as they were with other
things for example in an interview
descendants to director Kenny Ortega
admitted that one of the reasons he cast
Mitchell hope is Fenn was because he
wasn't the best dancer in the world in
fact he said it was a real plus point
for the character because it gave him
more of an everyman quality well as much
as the prints son of Belle and beast
could be an everyman and talking a beast
the actor who plays him in the
descendant franchise dan Payne has also
admitted to getting a bit nervous when
he had to film a dance sequence
he said that shooting the scene where
his character danced was the scariest
bit of the movie for him he wouldn't
know it when you saw it though why is
dub Cameron dove Cameron so if we ask
who is dub Cameron we bet every single
one of you will be able to say a lot of
things about her she's a brilliant
young actors who plays Mao in The
Descendants movies of course but there's
a sad and interesting fact about death
Cameron that we think you may not have
known and that is that her name isn't
really dub or at least it wasn't
originally she was originally named
Chloe but her father Philip Alan hawse
Herman used to call her dove when she
was a little girl although her parents
divorced and her mother remarried which
is why we know her as dub Cameron not
dump Osterman she stayed close to her
father
however tragedy struck when dove or
Chloe was 15 years old in 2011 her
father tragically took his own life dove
was understandably distraught however
she paid tribute to her late father in
what we think is a heartbreaking Lee
perfect way when it was time for her to
become a star of the screen she took the
stage named um so it's like every time
someone calls heard of it's like her dad
is living on it's an absolutely
wonderful tribute to him and we will
admit we feel a bit emotional talking
about it Dylan lets things slip if you
were a fan of the first descendants
movie then you'll know just how exciting
it was waiting for descendants -
everyone had their own theories about
what was going to happen and who would
be in it and when we saw the poster we
scoured it for clues about the film and
we also tried to see if there was any
sign of an official release date but
people who knew who was in the film and
followed them on social media might well
have got an accidental exclusive about
when descendants 2 was due to come out
that's because a new member of the cast
accidentally let it slip if you follow
Dylan Playfair who was announced as
playing Gil in the run-up to the release
of the movie on Instagram then you might
have found out something very
interesting and important that is
because Dylan posted The Descendants -
release date of June 23rd 2017 on the
image sharing app although he was pretty
quick to delete the post it caught on
and soon most descendants fans were in
on the information we don't know if
Dylan got punished for a slip if he did
we hope it wasn't too severe now and
Harry if you're as crazy about the
descendents franchise as we are that we
think you pay attention to what it is
the stars of the movies have to say it
looks like a lot of them are as much
fans of the series as we are Doug
Cameron had a great theory about her
character she thinks mal was also dating
Harry hook when she was younger
the actors even think that they had
secret tattoos but she ended up breaking
his heart moved on and found someone
else that's what gave them weird tension
and why he hates Ben and mal being
together Dov even thinks that Harry
loved Emma but unfortunately for him she
didn't love him back either we can think
of a lot of descendants fans who would
love Harry Dov concluded by saying
that's why he hates me so much
she's like a broken man because of that
however if you've been paying attention
to what dubs been up to you'll note that
there is a pretty awesome subtext to
that and that is the Dove is dating
Thomas Doherty who plays Harry so maybe
that could have motivated Dov to come up
with her theory dub versus Chyna am on
this screen it is pretty clear that
Malin Ummah from descendants two really
don't like each other but off screen it
looks like the of Cameron and China and
MacLean or good friends or are they
around the time that the movie hit our
screens there were rumors that the two
were involved in a few the source for
this bit of gossip was at first glance a
bit weird
there was a video on YouTube called car
sentence in it some of the film's cast
were captured on video singing umas
what's my name song but some people
thought that dub was looking at Chyna am
pretty oddly this ended up sparking a
lot of controversy as it seemed to
suggest that dub had some kind of beef
with Chyna and it became such a big deal
that Dov had to step in and correct
people she posted on Twitter that she
had no idea where the rumors came from
and she said it was time that they
stopped but they were so widespread she
even sent records of conversations she
had had with her co-star and Chyna an
also jumped in telling people that she
loved up so that was one weird rumor but
we're glad Dov and Chyna and corrected
things what you didn't see when movies
get made there's always seen that end up
on the cutting room floor quite often
it's through no fault of their own is
just that the movies makers want to trim
their work down a bit and that was true
of descendants too however if they had
stayed in the completed film then it
might have been quite a different
experience for instance if you are a fan
of the song if only from the first film
then you should know that it could have
ended up in the second there was a scene
of mal singing it but it got left out
much to our disappointment and did you
know there were several different
versions of the ending in the completed
film we see uma turned to the camera and
say he didn't think this was the end of
the story did he but the movies creators
also filmed a version with Harry
Tsang the line and best of all he says
it in a very dark in mysterious way and
dizzy Tremaine also said the line but in
a lovely sweet and innocent way which
makes sense considering she's pretty
much the opposite of Harry and numa's
characters we think that changing the
end would have given both descendants -
and descendants three a different flavor
the descendants three announcement if
you love descendants - then you're now
waiting for news about the third movie
was pretty agonizing although umas final
lineup you didn't think this was the end
of the story did you reflected mouths
from the first film we could only hope
that Disney would continue the franchise
so when the announcement came in
February 2018 that there would be a
descendants three it was a surprise
and release but fans weren't the only
people who weren't aware that there was
going to be a third film that's because
the cast of descendants - were also kept
in the dark about it stars like dub
Cameron Cameron Boyce in China and
McClain admitted after the second movie
came out that they did not know if there
was going to be a third part to the
story so Disney must have been pretty
secretive because it wasn't that long
between the release of the second film
and the announcement about the third
which we can kind of understand but we
still feel a bit sorry for the actors
who were left up in the air about it but
we wondered whether there were any other
things Disney might not want us to know
about The Descendants movies don't be
shy let us know in the comments and
that's all for our ten dark secrets and
descendants Disney doesn't want you to
know thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to the things